we can't be joy later I am Ken enjoy
doing I can do it oh this one you gotta
close your eyes though you should do
both sides at the same time 100 my brain
was fried for a sec I like this
I don't know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
but it's a ferris wheel of some sort you
guys already know I'm extremely afraid
of heights looking at this thing as we
get closer we start to realize how
[ __ ] tall the [ __ ] is I am disposed
to killing myself I don't want to do
this brush peer pressure and I want to
show you about nine months and I'm going
to [ __ ] are you excited she made that
don't want me to be able to point you in
the face no you face she here what about
my boobs
sexual harassment I know perfectly fine
and okay hurts or tender we need a bra I
don't need a bra ha ha ha what I need is
somebody to squeeze their face into
these he needs a boiling it for me real
huh man should be doing men I need head
to do it you mean I say that to my
brother of yours me that's a blood the
more body but you got titties funny guys
gets the ladies you know I'm saying it's
all about the giggles because you guys
can invest yourself into a six-pack and
good looks that [ __ ] goes away sense of
humor lasts forever I'll make you
laughter you [ __ ] die
this is not a ferris wheel look at this
[ __ ] that's huge yeah
fairy tales can be this big oh it's a
fancy one look you're in close she set
up to 40 people fit here yeah 40 hello
Jim very rare it'll be open I would
never let my children do this even it
really busy
daddy please no this is this thing is
being held up I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] about my pitch the one of is
Ilana scared I never go on that oh my
god dude this is crazy
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't understand this like I don't
understand a human psyche of wanting to
go in things that potentially could kill
you
how does your hand feel
we're no longer friends is how it feels
all right
no is that April already
Chilean on occasion it's $25 you have
much beat or soaking through these shoes
right now
I can't wait he's on and [ __ ] those
babies they don't know [ __ ] yet babies
are the most ignorant little things on
earth they would go up to the mouth of a
[ __ ] lion and lay in it if they could
that that comparison never makes any
sense there's babies and of course the
babies in their babies oh no [ __ ]
number one they had us walk into this
while the orb was moving that is very
dangerous
number two they got a thin little
fishnet how is that going to stop me I
will fall right through that [ __ ] this
is dangerous
yeah I don't know if I can live like
this you should break dance oh look at
that beautiful there's a being a part of
my oh I want to take pictures blood to
skin you know I didn't used to be this
scared of heights and I don't know what
happened
I think I had a general like consentual
that I care about living and then the
fear came god
[ __ ] you want your strip - that's right
- one
I'm very petty I stood up with a few
moments so thank you
oh she has a motherly touch in love she
chastises be like she's my mother and
also congratulations big good job all
you needed the kiss on the forehead but
you have a really greasy private or head
right now said I wanna kids cuz of the
fear of the sweat I'm proud of ya buddy
sister yeah he told me to be about
that's rude it well you've been [ __ ]
up your whole life how do you feel now
that you're here rien value tired life
good you have a job your job sucks deal
with it
have a good time we're nearing the end
of our journey together I know not going
to be easy for me but people roll hard
experience was fantastic I'm glad that I
faced my fears
would you do it again no I'm good I'm
absolutely okay with it maybe one day
when I get rid of my career hide that's
right I get that creepy guy right then
offered you a job I want to do that
you're an idiot you spent $25 to come up
to see absolutely nothing how do you
feel now reevaluate your life it's not
what he told us he told us to reevaluate
our lives that's terrible I'll remember
you guys forever
I'll miss you even though I've never
actually met you and this is just a
video so I'm lying I am a liar what are
you doing I'm a serial killer
basically I kill people on the weekends
but every now is then I make videos
where I look at my hand and I waited you
like
minute that's good you're gonna fit the
back camera why are we here you
interviewed out there no no because what
you wanted to do is with anyone I'm not
a bad friend like that it's business fun
it's not your fault
I'm not scared of fighting people I'm
not scared of confrontation but if you
put me near Heights I turn into this
the tunnel money to ice up he's walking
like that cuz his diapers in the way you
know he always